me now is 2024 Republican presidential
candidate Vivek ramaswamy Vivek I think
the Democrats are sensing that their
lock on the black vote may be you know
breaking even the Washington Post is
writing about a drop in turnout
potentially among black voters
especially those who are young and male
and also there was this focus group that
Politico did this week and it was a
small focus group but they the title of
this piece is pathetic voters of color
slam Biden's performance on the economy
6 and 10 saying they're not satisfied
with his job uh and handling the economy
how significant is this
I think this is a very significant
opportunity Laura if the Republican
party has the good sense to step up and
seize it I saw this firsthand myself I
visited the south side of Chicago just a
couple of months ago I also went to
Kensington in the middle of Philadelphia
I will tell you Laura it is not what you
expect I have never been in a room
perhaps more ardently pro border wall
and pro-military On the Border then the
group of a predominantly black audience
on the south side of Chicago because
they're turning a local High School
South Shore High School into an
encampment for migrants who are getting
treated better than people in that
community and so I think this is a real
opportunity for us to say the America
first movement stands for yes all
Americans and if we stand on that
principle to say that we will put the
interests of the citizens of this nation
first regardless Urban or Suburban black
or white we stand for the interests of
our citizens over those reporting into
zielinski or whoever Halfway Around the
world I think that's actually a very
powerful message that transcends
partisan boundaries and if I'm the
nominee or as I expect and hope to be we
will bring along voters of diverse
shades of melanin in droves and win this
election in a landslide
you know as we said in the open of the
show like the the Democrats only have
the politics of racial Division and so
that's why you have the you know the
commentators coming out and saying well
we need black majority states in the
United States you know missing the fact
that blacks are already moving back to
the South because it's a better economy
and now Vivek conservatives are pushing
back against this politics of racial
division Progressive Insurance has been
sued by America First legal for patently
unlawful racism by offering twenty five
thousand dollar grants to help black
owned businesses buy vehicles but
barring white asian Latino and other
entrepreneurs from applying this is part
of the corporate scam you've been trying
to expose
it is and you know it's almost ironical
or I'm hearing you say it Progressive
Insurance sales it's almost as they
tried to actually even put it in the
name and turn it into a branding
exercise the reality is these are civil
rights violations hiding in plain sight
I know color blindness is deemed to be
racist by the modern woke left I reject
that narrative I think colorblind
meritocracy is part of what it means to
be an American you and I have different
shades of melanin you and I are two
different genders so what our diversity
is meaningless unless there's something
greater that unites us across that
diversity and I think this is our moment
as not just as conservatives but as
Americans to reawaken what actually
unites us across those different shades
of melanin that's what makes us American
and I will tell you Laura I think that
people regardless of their skin color
are really hungry for that in this
country you know what a lot of Americans
white and black alike have been duped
they understand the economies in the
toilet in their experience of it is no
different just because they're fed the
politics of racial Division if we stand
up and speak the truth we end up winning
well you just gotta let Kudos online
from Elon musk who seems to be perhaps
moving away maybe from DeSantis and
toward you very quickly your reaction on
that then I have one more question for
you
look I think Elon is an excellent
example of what he did at Twitter is a
good example of what I want to do to the
administrative State take out 75 percent
of that deadweight cost improve the
actual experience of what it's supposed
to do and at the same time I love the
way he released the Twitter files I'll
release the state action files anytime a
bureaucrat has pressured a private
company
for the for the world to see and he put
an X through Twitter I'll put a big X
through the administrative state so
that's where I'm at on common tactics
with Elon I'm just doing it to the
federal bureaucracy all right um Bill
Barr said something yesterday about the
Trump indictments watch
the federal cases are legitimate if
there's a chance to get it resolved
before the election it should be because
the American people should know these
are crimes involved or potential crimes
involve moral turpitude I think the
chances are that that he will be in he
will be convicted on some counts
Vivek
I mean if you're bringing hundreds of
counts across four different gate cases
it's like they're playing a probability
game of just shooting darts and seeing
what sticks Laura this sets an awful
precedent in our country general rule of
thumb if you're going to indict a former
U.S president who is running for
president in the middle of an election
at least don't make it novel legal
theories that have never been tested in
court and yet that's exactly what's the
case here in all four of these cases and
that is just shameful Laura and I'm
saying this as somebody who you know
there's new polls in the last 48 hours
putting me at second place in this race
it would be easier for me if Donald
Trump were eliminated from competition
that's not how I want to win that is not
right because that's not the way we do
things in the United States and you know
I do think we have an establishment that
spans both political parties that is
fundamentally hostile to one man who
happens to be one of my opponents in
this primary but I stand on the side of
Justice when I say I will stay true to
my commitment to Pardon Trump on day one
unambiguously and more importantly call
on Biden in the Department of Justice to
drop these prosecutions in the meantime
uh Vivek we'll see you next week at the
debate great to see you thanks hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else